hey guys justin here with a gamespot  news update the upcoming version of  ubisoft's motorcycle racing game trials  fusion runs at a higher resolution on  playstation 4 than xbox one according to  Ubisoft trials fusion will run in a  native 1080p on ps4 and a native 900p on  xbox one upscale to 1080p all versions  however will run at 60 frames per second  Microsoft has said that performance of  the xbox one should improve over time  but this resolution disparity has been  present on several titles including call  of duty ghosts battlefield 4 and  Assassin's Creed Black Flag the Xbox one  is fully capable of running games at  full HD resolution fortson motorsport 5  is a notable example of a game that runs  at 1080p 60 frames per second on the  xbox one trials fusion will also be  released on xbox 360 and pc console  versions will release on April sixteenth  and the pc version will be released  April 24 we've got all the latest  next-gen console news right at gamespot  com